une commande de sept millions de tests
antigénique pour un montant total de 50
millions d'euros l'autriche souhaite
procéder à un dépistage massif de sa
population dans les prochaines semaines
avec ces tests rapides
les autrichiens connaîtront leurs
résultats en 15 minutes
mais ce type d'examen est considéré
comme moins fiables que les tests pcr
le but de cette opération d'envergure
est d'offrir une alternative viable au
confinement et ainsi limiter les dégâts
pour l'économie nationale
nous voulons permettre aux gens de fêter
noël dans un cercle familial restreint
le dépistage de masse constitue
désormais une option efficace de
substitution au confinement de plusieurs
semaines nous demandons à l'ensemble de
la population de participer à ce projet
des chaînes nationales
car en attendant la vaccination ce
dépistage de masse est une grande chance
pour l'autriche de retrouver le chemin
de la normalité
ce dépistage massif se déroulera en
plusieurs étapes enseignants et
puériculture seront les premiers à
pouvoir se faire tester les 5 et 6
décembre prochains les 8,9 millions
d'habitants de l'autriche auront la
possibilité d'effectuer un test lors de
la semaine précédant les fêtes de fin
d'année mais également lors de la
première semaine de janvier
si la première vague de covit 19 au
printemps dernier avait plutôt épargné
l'autriche la deuxième est beaucoup plus
virulente
conséquence le gouvernement a choisi de
recombiner sa population depuis mardi
dernier et jusqu'au 6 décembre prochain
un cantonnement à la maison auquel les
locaux commencent à s'habituer
je pense que nous nous habituons à cette
nouvelle façon de vivre est en fait il
n'y a pas de problème avec le
confinement cette fois ci parce que les
gens savent ce qu'ils peuvent faire et
ne pas faire
mais c'était une fiction c'est
évidemment nécessaire pour réduire le
nombre d'infections à l'heure actuelle
l'autriche et malheureusement dans le
groupe de tête avec plus de 500 cas pour
100000 habitants soit lors des taux les
plus élevés d'europe
il faut que le réduire parce qu'après
tout y est
je pense que c'est logique parce que
l'on ne sait pas comment la situation
évolue réellement si tout ça n'était pas
en train de se passer
je pense que l'on peut l'accepter ça va
mal pour l'économie et les entreprises
mais ça peut aussi aller mal si on ne
prend pas toutes ces mesures le
gouvernement autrichien espère avoir
choisi la bonne direction en testant
massivement mais l'autriche n'est pas le
premier pays à s'être dirigé sur la voie
du dépistage général de sa population en
slovaquie les autorités ont testé 3,6
millions de personnes en un week-end
début novembre soit deux tiers de la
population une première mondiale pour
une campagne de tests à grande échelle